Speaker 1: Why don't we go next
Speaker 2: to Terry from
Speaker 1: Fresno? Terry, you were on the air.
Speaker 4:
Hey, David, how's it going?
Speaker 1: It's going well, thank you.
Speaker 4: So I wanted to ask about the
idea of optics and intra political issues,
because it seems like optics don't really
matter. Across party lines, but in so far as like
like a Democrat on Democrat, like what's
the purpose of arguing optics and something
when that's clearly not what's happening?
Speaker 2: I don't know what you mean.
Speaker 1: So give me give me an example
of an argument Democrats have with each
other about optics. What's an example
Speaker 4: like the optics of AOC going to
the Met Gala wearing a dress? That's his tax.
Speaker 2: The rich, OK?
Speaker 4: Like, there have been arguments about
like, Oh, it's not a good look for somebody who
is fighting for income inequality,
who is going to like the Met Gala,
where a bunch of rich people are?
Speaker 1: Oh, I see. And then there
was the counterpoint, which was like, No,
it's great that she was there because she
was a she was something different instead of just
celebrities and whatever. And that's exactly like
that. That debate you're talking about.
Speaker 4: Yeah. Things of that nature.
Because like ultimately, I think
it obscures like actual issues.
Speaker 1: I tend to
Speaker 2: agree
with you. I tend to agree with you.
Speaker 1: So for me, that debate was
not interesting. For me, the optics debate that's
more interesting is actually one that's between
Republicans and Democrats. And I'll give you an
example and tell me if you think this is more
more relevant and interesting. We've talked about
hypocrisy in politics before, and we've talked
about how, you know, take take foreign policy
first. Republicans said it's patriotic to go
to war when it was the Iraq War, and then with
Obama, Obama was unpatriotic because he wasn't
willing to start wars and he was going to leave
the country open to attacks. But then when it was
Speaker 2: Donald Trump, the patriotic
Speaker 1: thing
Speaker 2: again was he won't
Speaker 1: get us into wars,
but Hillary will. And then now with Joe
Biden, it's why is Joe Biden giving Russia
warnings? So they're totally hypocritical, right?
The the the problem is the right doesn't care
about their own hypocrisy, whether while the
Speaker 2: left does seem to
Speaker 1: care about
Speaker 2: hypocrisy, that's really
Speaker 1: interesting to me because it
raises questions of should the left also stop
caring about hypocrisy and double standards? Or
how do you take advantage of the hypocrisy of
Speaker 2: the right if their voters don't
Speaker 1: care about the
Speaker 2: hypocrisy? For me, that's
Speaker 1: like an optics debate
that's much more relevant and substantive.
Speaker 4: Yeah, and I can understand that,
although I would say from my perspective, you
can't win a basketball game if your opponents have
guns and are shooting people. Sure. I mean, like,
you have to play the same game that everybody else
is playing. So like to me, the optics conversation
in so far as like they don't care about hypocrisy,
but we do that conversation. It just stops because
like if you're not willing to play the same game
and you're already losing, you know what I mean?
Speaker 1: I agree. And this gets to to a
lot of our discussions about
Speaker 2: without committing
Speaker 1: crimes or doing straight up immoral
things. Democrats have to recognize that we
have to use the system. We have to try to win
or otherwise the system will just get worse.
Speaker 4: Yeah, and to some degree, I don't
think I I'm not wholly against and granted,
I'm very much so on the political extreme like
I am for a long time, I was like one of those
people who was all about the spirit of the game,
right? Like, you play basketball, right? Yeah.
So when you go play basketball, you respect the
foul. If somebody calls a foul, you're playing
a pickup game, you just respect the call. Sure,
I'll argue it. You don't do all that. But like
if you're playing against people who argue calls
and will just shave points off and do all sorts,
then what's the point in playing the game if
you're not going to do the same thing, right?
Speaker 1: I guess the question is yes. Yes,
exactly. Unless the problem becomes when things
are more life or death than basketball and you
end up with really bad options of having to
degrade yourself,
Speaker 2: maybe or
Speaker 1: just let them be the only
players, which is also terrible that
you got. You got some tough decisions to make.
Speaker 4: You absolutely degrade yourself in
every instance. So you kidding me? If the choice
is like letting a bunch of your constituents
maybe lose the right to have abortions and
like maybe playing a little bit unfair or
doing the same things that Republicans do,
then I feel like the option every time is
do what's best for your constituents?
Speaker 2: Right, right, right. Right.
Speaker 1: All right. Very important issues. I
appreciate you bringing them to me today. Thank
you. All right. Let's take a very quick break.
We are going to keep taking calls right after
this short break. So if you are holding. Don't
hang up. We're going right back to the phones.